[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia soy andrés suárez jaramillo los
acuerdos de paz en colombia' que
pusieron fin a 50 años de conflicto
armado directo entre la ex guerrilla de
las farc y los diferentes gobiernos de
turno cumplen 5 años de haberse firmado
un hito para la historia de este país
suramericano pero como surgió y se
desarrolló este conflicto que tanto
atormentó a los colombianos y que causó
más de
262.000 muertos y cerca de 6 millones de
desplazados internos según datos del
centro de memoria histórica para
responder a esta pregunta debemos
remontarnos a mediados del siglo 20
cuando en colombia se libraba una época
conocida como la violencia una
confrontación bipartidista entre
liberales y conservadores que tuvo como
consecuencia la creación de autodefensas
campesinas en este contexto en el año
1964 nació en las montañas del centro de
colombia un enclave fundado por dos
hombres entre los que se destaca a pedro
antonio marín alias tirofijo quien hasta
su muerte en 2008 fue la figura más
emblemática
de la guerrilla de las farc desde su
fundación en la década del 60 y casi
hasta finales de la década del 70 las
farc se mantuvieron marginales poco
combativas casi silenciosas pero llegó
un episodio clave en la séptima
conferencia en mayo de 1982 que reunió a
cerca de 30 frentes de combate fue el
parteaguas para que las farc dejaran la
clandestinidad la séptima conferencia
fue el momento en que las farc se
rebautizaron como farc ep el ejército
del pueblo y decidieron expandir su
influencia y pie de fuerza en todo el
país viendo el avance insurgente el por
entonces presidente belisario betancur
propició en 1984 los primeros acuerdos
de paz con la guerrilla en los cuales
ofreció las garantías para que los
guerrilleros pudieran militar en
política integrándose al partido de
izquierda y unión patriótica
estigmatizado como el ala política de
las farc la upe fue el blanco de lo que
la justicia reconoció posteriormente un
genocidio político perpetrado por
autodefensas paramilitares una alianza
de sectores de extrema derecha
terratenientes ganaderos y miembros de
la fuerza pública se estima que a lo
largo de 20 años más de 3.000 personas
fueron asesinadas
habiéndose las farc refugiado nuevamente
en las montañas del centro y oriente de
colombia para la década de 1990
ampliaron su músculo militar por la
incursión a gran escala en el
narcotráfico fueron los peores años del
conflicto con cruentos enfrentamientos
atentados tomas de bases militares y un
desangramiento de todos los actores
inmersos guerrilla fuerzas armadas
grupos paramilitares y población civil
en 1998 un nuevo intento de acuerdo de
paz con el gobierno del presidente
andrés pastrana se vio nuevamente
frustrado por el incumplimiento de las
farc y dejó en evidencia la ineficacia
del gobierno para contener el avance de
los insurgentes los esfuerzos
internacionales para una reingeniería de
las fuerzas militares se concretaron
principalmente con el plan colombia un
pacto concebido en 1999 y destinado a
fortalecer las fuerzas armadas y a
luchar contra el narcotráfico
eeuu invirtió entre 2001 y 2016 más de
10 mil millones de dólares en ayuda
militar en 2002 los colombianos
eligieron al presidente álvaro uribe
abiertamente declarado enemigo de las
farc su política de seguridad
democrática aún no esfuerzos para
combatir a la guerrilla con unas fuerzas
armadas revitalizadas por la inyección
de capital extranjero en 2008 terminando
el mandato de uribe murió de un infarto
a los 77 años alias tirofijo el por
entonces guerrillero más viejo del mundo
y co-fundador de las farc estas
operaciones las del gobierno uribe
contra la guerrilla habían sido
lideradas por el ministro de defensa
juan manuel santos el éxito obtenido más
el respaldo del propio uribe le valieron
ser elegido como el nuevo presidente de
los colombianos en su primer mandato
santos continuó con la ofensiva militar
contra la guerrilla al punto de abatir
alias alfonso cano el comandante que
había sucedido a tirofijo como líder de
las farc el propio presidente santos
reveló que fue este comandante con quien
se realizaron los primeros contactos
para una aproximación con miras a unos
diálogos de paz
justamente con la posibilidad de
reelegirse el presidente santos prometió
que en su segundo mandato traería la paz
para todos los colombianos su campaña
fue un éxito y venció al candidato de
uribe que estaba en contra de dialogar
con las farc en este contexto nacieron
los acuerdos de oslo y de la habana en
2012 en los cuales el equipo negociador
del gobierno y el secretariado de las
farc discutieron temas agrarios la
participación en política a través de un
partido con curules en el congreso la
dejación de armas la reparación y el
reconocimiento de las víctimas del
conflicto la reincorporación de los
guerrilleros a la vida civil y todo esto
amparado bajo un sistema conocido como
la red la justicia especial para la paz
en 2016 y tras cuatro años de diálogos
texto para poner fin al conflicto armado
de 50 años estaba terminado santos había
prometido que la última palabra la
tendrían los colombianos así que sometió
los acuerdos de paz de la habana a un
referendo en el que sorpresivamente la
opción del no se impuso por la mínima
diferencia aún así santos aprobó los
acuerdos por la vida del decreto
presidencial y se firmaron el 24 de
noviembre del mismo año
hoy cinco años después colombia se
encuentra sumida en una profunda
polarización entre quienes defienden la
paz y aseguran que las promesas no han
sido cumplidas y quienes denuncian un
acuerdo rechazado por la mayoría y que
abre según ellos la puerta a la
impunidad así concluimos hoy andrés
suárez jaramillo gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]